in early 2022 action star and Hollywood
legend Bruce Willis stepped away from
acting piece of news was particularly
poignant because of the reason for his
retirement Aphasia a language disorder
that affects a person's ability to
communicate often caused by Strokes
brain injuries tumors or in Willis's
case dementia even though the word
language comes from the Latin for tongue
language is really more related to the
brain than any other part of the body
it's where language happens whether
you're shaping words with your mouth
signing them with your hands or writing
them on paper the bulk of the work is
going on up here while there is no one
part of the brain that handles
everything speech related there are some
areas that are more involved than others
scientists have known this long before
the development of MRIs and other brain
scanning Technologies how through the
study and observation of patients who
have experienced language impairments
due to brain damage by determining what
has been lost or impaired
neuroscientists have been better able to
understand how our brains process
language and what language really is and
now my brain language connection will
communicate that to you I'm Dr Erica
brazovsky and this is other words
[Music]
other words
to learn more about the relationship
between language and the Brain I spoke
with Dr Alexander tan a pediatric
neuropsychologist with expertise in the
assessment of neurological and
neurodevelopmental disorders in Children
and adolescents so you're a
neuropsychologist what is
neuropsychology the definition of
neuropsychology literally is the study
of brain and behavior in that
relationship so as a pediatric
neuropsychologist we do checkups on
different brain functions like attention
memory visual perception language and
then using those results we can assess
for brain disorders and make sure that
we are getting children the treatments
and supports that they might need and
track their development or their
recovery over time when it comes to the
connection between language and the
Brain the first answers were discovered
in sort of a curious way prior to
technological advances in neuroimaging
like functional MRIs doctors couldn't
see what was happening in the brain and
observe what areas lit up with various
stimuli the only way to look at the
brain was by opening it up in the 19th
century Physicians Paul broca and Carl
vernica separately discovered two
regions of the brain through conducting
autopsies on aphasic patients Dr abroka
and Dr bernicke were able to locate
specific parts of the brain that have
resulting impacts on their ability to
either Express language or to comprehend
language and those parts now referred to
as Broca's area and where to Keys area
are in the left frontal or left temporal
lobe respectively and that was one of
the first signals to us that the left
hemisphere is dominant for language for
more than 95 percent of right-handed
people and sixty percent of left-handed
people the left hemisphere is dominant
for language but that's not to say that
the language parties exclusively on the
left side now that we've had more
advancements in technology different
kinds of Imaging techniques we now are
seeing that language actually involves a
lot of different parts of the brain
including you know implicating all four
lobes the gray matter and the white
matter cortical and subcortical
structures it's very much a complex
ability that involves communication and
coordination between a lot of different
parts of the brain when you see an image
say this one you think okay yeah sure
it's a ball or a car or a unicorn but
that's just the result let's backtrack
to what happened on the inside first you
process the visual input so that you
could recognize the object then you have
to convert the input into a semantic
concept from there you search through
your mental Rolodex of abstract
representations and pick the concept
matching word finally you articulate the
phonemes that make up that word and if
just one step doesn't work properly you
might not be able to recognize the
object or know what it's for or find the
word you need or communicate the word to
anyone else what is aphasia first of all
and what causes it
so Aphasia is essentially an impairment
in language abilities and it is uh
typically caused by Strokes brain
injuries that affect certain parts of
the brain or some kind of
neurodegenerative condition like
dementias or Alzheimer's disease the two
most common types of aphasias are the
ones named after broca and vernica
damage to Broca's area may cause brocos
Aphasia or expressive Aphasia which
means you can generally understand
others but of difficulty getting your
words out it might be limited to single
words or short phrases on the other hand
someone suffering from vernica's Aphasia
or receptive aphasia will have trouble
understanding language even their own
but is still capable of fluid competent
speech they may talk a long nonsensical
yet grammatically correct sentences
there's a white matter Highway between
Broca's area and Wernicke's area called
the archaeophysicalist that communicates
between the two and so sometimes when
there's impact to that there's something
called conduction Aphasia where our
expression is intact our comprehension
is intact but because we can't integrate
the two then it's hard for us to repeat
language that we hear in other cases
extensive deterioration of the brain
such as various types of dementia can
lead to Global Aphasia where all three
factors fluency understanding and
repetition are impaired and what kind of
treatments are available for people who
are experiencing Aphasia our main
treatment for the Aphasia specifically
usually focuses on rehabilitation in the
form of speech and language therapy we
always want to have supportive
treatments in place for some of the side
effects individuals with Aphasia or at
risk for things like depression and
Social isolation you know our brains
deteriorate faster with the absence of
social connection uh so it's really
important for individuals with Aphasia
and for those supporting them to find
you know alternate ways to communicate
with them and continue to integrate them
socially and just making sure that we're
patient with them as they try to find
the words
know that the brain changes over the
course of our lives and it generally
comes to maturity in the mid to late 20s
during childhood are neuroplasticity or
the ability of networks in the brain to
grow and change is at its highest levels
if for example children have seizures on
the left side there's this crowding
effect that we sometimes observe where
language kind of reorganizes onto the
right side of the brain to preserve
itself and sometimes crowds out the
other functions that were typically
associated with the right size so
sometimes resulting in weaknesses to
non-verbal and visual skills so is the
brain prioritizing language above
significant other functions in general
is that something that the brain
generally prioritizes yes the brain does
tend to try to preserve language
abilities
language is so important to be able to
communicate to learn to navigate the
world socially the brain will reorganize
however it can to make sure language
function is preserved is it possible to
improve your neuroplasticity as an adult
yeah sure there's always ways that you
know the typical things that our doctors
tell us that we never listen to right
making sure that we're really taking
care of our sleep our exercise our diet
learning a new language is a really
great one that really forces our brain
to activate all those parts of the brain
that are really important for not just
language learning but also code
switching and executive functioning the
brain is an incredibly capable and
resilient machine and scientists are
learning new things about the brain
language connection every day what is
something you've learned about the twin
brain over the course of your career
that you think everyone should know the
number one thing I've learned about the
brain is just that there's always more
to learn about the brain we've made big
you know very large strides in terms of
understanding how parts of the brain
correlate with brain function but there
are just so many answers that we still
don't have and that's just what makes it
eternally fascinating to me language is
one of the things that makes us human
and because of that it is invaluable to
us as a species any loss of language or
communication ability is a tragedy but
by the groundwork laid through studying
language to the lens of brain damage
we've come to understand the pieces that
make up human language how injury
affects them and how to apply that
information to improve the lives of
those who are affected
you may also remember from a previous
episode that swearing relies just as
much on the right side of the brain so
don't expect someone with left side
brain damage to swear any left left oh
no